[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JT des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité plus de 2 millions
de visiteurs au rendez-vous de départ de
la Route du Rhum cela fait les bonnes
affaires de Saint-Malo plus rentables
encore qu'un mois d'août vous le verrez
avec la TVR sur place elles sont partout
dans nos rues les trottinettes
électriques ont envahi les villes depuis
quelques années malgré leur apparente
simplicité leur utilisation reste
soumise à des règles de bonne conduite
pas assez appliquée malheureusement
reportage de Vosges télévision dans ce
journal
plus de 7 décennies dans le monde du
journalisme à 92 ans Philippe Bouvard
vient de publier un nouveau livre le
petit monde de don-beauvardo aux
éditions de l'archipel l'occasion idéale
pour m'accorder un entretien depuis son
domicile à Cannes vous découvrirez en
avant-première un extrait de cette
interview où il se confie notamment sur
sa carrière
la chapelle Sixtine comme si vous y
étiez mais depuis Bordeaux en fin
d'édition TV7 la chaîne du groupe
sud-ouest nous conduira dans les
coulisses de l'exposition phare
consacrée au génie de Michel-Ange et à
la Renaissance italienne
près de 6500 km sur l'Atlantique 138
skipper au départ et un seul objectif
arrivé le premier en Guadeloupe la 12e
édition de la Route du Rhum partira
depuis la ville de Saint-Malo un
événement pour la commune qui accueille
jusqu'à 2 millions de visiteurs pour
l'occasion une bonne nouvelle aussi pour
l'économie locale qui surf ainsi sur la
vague de la mythique course reportage
sur place de TVR
206 deuxième étage à l'image de l'hôtel
Escale Océania et ses 88 chambres la
ville de Saint-Malo connaît l'influence
des grands jours à l'occasion de la
Route du Rhum une édition qui bat tous
les records cette année avec près de 2
millions de personnes attendues pour le
patron de l'Océania c'est plus 20% de
chiffre d'affaires par rapport à l'année
dernière et des réservations qui se font
un an à l'avance cet effet Route du Rhum
permet de rallonger la saison tout
simplement et puis les lendemains de la
Route du Rhum il y a toujours plus
d'activités ça fait bien parler de notre
capacité corsaires ça c'est indéniable
côté restauration le bilan et le même
les terrasses et brasseries du
centre-ville sont d'ores et déjà prise
d'assaut et pour répondre à cette
demande il faut bien sûr renforcer les
équipes donc la Route du Rhum représente
un 13e mois dans l'année et pas
n'importe lequel puisque ça représente
un mois d'août et une préparation de
plusieurs semaines pour pour accueillir
tous ces toutes ces personnes là d'une
formation nous faisons appel à des
extras mais également au lycée hôtelier
de Dinard et au-delà des retombées
économ certaines la Route du Rhum c'est
aussi d'importantes retomber médiatique
pour la cité corsaire ces 227 nuitées
supplémentaires à l'occasion de la Route
du Rhum donc on voit bien qu'il y a des
effets immédiats et puis il y a aussi
des effets en termes de promotion
d'attractivité d'image du territoire où
on a de nombreuses personnes qui
viennent à Saint-Malo ou qui regardent
le départ de la Route du Rhum et qui
décide l'année suivant la route du Rhum
de revenir les tendances sont toujours
similaires c'est une année après la
Route du Rhum un engouement particulier
justement pour venir sur notre
territoire
il durera lui c'est certain plus d'une
semaine l'hiver ne débutera
officiellement que le 21 décembre
prochain néanmoins les températures ont
commencé à baisser ces derniers jours
sur une bonne partie du territoire une
baisse qui rime bien sûr avec le retour
du chauffage et des factures qui
pourraient exploser dans ce contexte
actuel dans la somme de nombreux
habitants se chauffent encore au fioul
alors pour un moindre rire les coups le
maire d'un village propose désormais des
commandes groupées à ses habitants
objectif obtenir une ristourne de la
part des fournisseurs reportages et
explications de Jérémie Houbron pour oui
au TV la chaîne de la Voix du Nord
Viviane est parait pour affronter
l'hiver là j'ai deux queues de 1000
litres et je viens de faire remplir une
de mes cuves cet habitant d'Eppeville
vient de se faire livrer 1000 litres de
fioul et une facture salée de 1550 euros
soit 1 € 55 le litre de fioul l'un
75 centimes plus il me restait ça alors
du coup je l'ai je l'ai j'en ai
recommandé pour finir après l'année
prochaine on verra en deux ans ça dépend
pour 1000 litres de fioul c'est alourdi
de 530 euros alors pour faire baisser la
facture elle a opté pour la commande
groupée une idée lancée par la
municipalité il y a de moi on a fait des
formulaires pour les administrer de
façon à ce que il demande ce qu'ils
avaient besoin et puis voilà après nous
on a démarché un fournisseur de fioul au
lieu d'un 74 à peu près ça fait les gens
vont payer un euro 55 15 centimes d'euro
une ristourne bienvenue dans un contexte
d'inflation jamais vu auparavant en à
peine un an le prix du fioul a déjà
augmenté de 71%
dire entre guillemets raisonnable que
dans pleine période de froid ou
obligatoirement les prix vont monter
pour cette grande première 29 et
peuvillois ont commandé du fioul par
l'intermédiaire de la mairie qui
envisage d'effectuer une nouvelle
commande groupée en février prochain
et si pour faire des économies vous
passiez au vélo l'idée encouragée par le
gouvernement comme les entreprises
séduit de plus en plus de français à
Nîmes une société propose une prime de
400 euros à tous les salariés qui font
le choix de ce mode de transport pour
leur trajet domicile travail une aide
qui semble convaincre les concernés
comme a pu le constater Loris à Merlin
pourvient Occitanie regardez
en commun et donc ça peut être un
véhicule hybride ou électrique une prime
qui peut se cumuler avec la prise en
charge par l'employeur de 50% de
l'abonnement de transport en commun
voilà et en plus des déplacements à vélo
ou à pied l'économie circulaire est-elle
aussi très utile pour préserver
l'environnement parmi les ressources mal
exploitées les déchetteries représentent
de vrais mines d'or vous allez le voir à
Thonon-les-Bains plus de 500 tonnes
d'objets jetés par an sont en parfait
état où sont réutilisables et c'est pour
les exploiter qu'une ressourcerie a été
créée par plusieurs associations
Victoria Lopez a suivi le parcours d'un
déchet sauvé de Labenne un sujet de la
rédaction de 8 Mont-Blanc
le geste est simple mais lourd de
conséquences dans le Chablais 500 tonnes
d'objets sont gaspillés chaque année ils
se retrouvent dans ses bennes alors
qu'il pourrait encore faire des heureux
les bénévoles et les salariés de la
remise ont donc décidé de collecter
directement dans les déchetteries les
objets et les meubles en bon état on est
dans une région où la ressource le
gisement est énorme on a énormément
d'objets de qualité qui sont jetés et à
côté de ça ben il y a des personnes qui
tiennent sont difficultés ont du mal
nous on vient collecter en déchetterie
et c'est ça la nouveauté du modèle c'est
que nous on supprime du gaspillage on
s'engage à 300 tonnes par an dans ces
caisses son rangés les plus petits
objets alors que les meubles sont
chargés directement dans le camion ils
sont ensuite transportés dans cette
ressourcerie la remise fondée par cette
association dispose d'un véritable
centre commercial dans cet espace un
atelier de réhabilitation des objets et
meuble a été installé au cœur du lieu un
espace d'échange et d'animation a été
aménagé autour du bar des ateliers et
autres événements y seront organisés
l'espace dispose aussi d'une véritable
boutique où seront vendues les objets
collectés et remis à neuf on a créé sur
ce site 30 emplois non délocalisables et
dans ces 30 emplois il y a 20 postes en
insertion donc c'est aussi un projet
social on a mis un million trois
investissements donc c'est pas rien les
pouvoirs publics nous suivent de
nombreuses fondations privées aussi on a
des partenaires l'épicerie sociale a
déjà ouvert ses portes dans les locaux
solidarité encore dans ce journal pour
évoquer à présent l'inquiétante
situation du Secours populaire français
l'association qui fournit notamment de
l'aide alimentaire peine à répondre à la
demande de ses bénéficiaires depuis la
rentrée a remis sur scène dans l'Aube
les rayons sont presque vides en cause
une demande en hausse et des dons en
baisse les détails avec son reportage de
Canal 32 sur place
a remis sur scène les rayonnages de
Secours populaire pour la distribution
alimentaire sont quasiment vides donc on
a encore une vingtaine de familles à
servir on sait pas comment on va faire
d'habitude c'est rempli comment ici
cette pénurie simplifie depuis la
mi-septembre pour cette bénévole depuis
18 mois cette situation devient
intenable la veille d'une distribution
c'est tout ce qui nous restait comme
viande un saucisson et quatre steaks
hachés ici depuis la pandémie le nombre
de bénéficiaires à doubler 400 personnes
sont inscrites et leur nombre ne cessent
d'augmenter dans le même temps l'aide
européenne et le volume des ramasses
auprès des grandes surfaces baisse quand
on va à la banque alimentaire il y a
beaucoup moins de denrées mais c'est
parce que sûrement eux ils en ont moins
c'est pas et puis des supermarchés entre
ceux qui nous disent qu'il me donneront
plus et puis les autres on a plus grand
chose et on a quand même une grande
partie de nos bénévoles qui sont aussi
personnes les aider
et qui parfois ne prennent pas ce à quoi
elles ont droit en se disant ouais ben
la famille machin qui vient toutes les
semaines ils ont trois gosses moi j'en
ai pas quoi si la générosité persiste le
volume des collectes auprès des
particuliers ne couvrent pas les besoins
de distribution ces bénévoles craignent
une dégradation de la situation déjà
critique on est à la croisée des chemins
où il y a une précarité alimentaire qui
augmente et une précarité des moyens du
SPF tout ça je sais pas comment ça va se
passer mais quand les gens vont avoir
froid et puis nous aussi peut-être parce
qu'on peut le chauffer je sais pas
comment ça va faire comment on va
pouvoir on aurait nos missions quoi ces
bénévoles ont prévu de rencontrer les
directions des grandes surfaces et
prépare une nouvelle collecte leur
objectif éviter de diminuer le nombre de
distribution
cela faisait des années qu'il
l'attendait les habitants d'un petit
village breton n'avait plus de café
depuis près de 15 ans grâce à
l'opération mille café un nouveau lieu
de vie vient de voir le jour une aubaine
pour les habitants qui peuvent ainsi se
rencontrer et renforcer le lien social
un sujet de Karine Chevrier pour Tébéo
la chaîne de groupe le télégramme à
Brest
après plus de dix années sans
café-restaurant la commune de
Saint-Germain croisant avec dans le
Morbihan 1400 habitants a depuis mars
dernier un nouveau lieu de vie et ses
habitués
on rencontre des gens qui habitent ici
et qu'on n'a jamais vu avant en fait
derrière le comptoir et au fourneau
jocelyne et Dominique le couple
d'Alsaciens a traversé l'Hexagone d'est
en ouest pour s'installer dans cette
commune rurale ce projet-là qui nous a
plu aussi c'est de redynamiser tous ces
villages ces petits bourgs la réalité a
besoin de reprendre vie et c'est un beau
lieu de rencontre parce qu'il y a des
personnes ça faisait 20 ans qui
s'étaient pas vu et qui se sont
retrouvés ici autour d'un café qui ont
pris discuter et c'est dans l'ancienne
mairie est presbytère de Saint gérant
que le café a vu le jour un
investissement a un peu plus de 200.000
euros pour la municipalité qui répond à
un besoin des habitants aux dernières
élections on avait demandé au géranet
qui est-ce qui a été intéressant soit un
bâtiment structurant ou quelque chose et
donc on avait fait un petit
questionnaire
et le questionnaire est arrivé sans
appel c'est à dire il voulait un café un
lieu de rencontre un lieu de vie et donc
c'était important pour eux le gérani et
le premier qui a fait restaurant
breton par le réseau
jour le réseau a pour mission de recréer
du lien social dans les petites communes
touchées par la désertification vous
accompagnons la gestion du café que ce
soit un point de vue économique que ce
soit un point de vue relationnel
communication déploiement des activités
c'est vraiment aiguillé donc les gérants
sur le développement de l'activité pour
en assurer sa pérennité
en Bretagne c'est un vieux vie sur
Couesnon en Ille-et-Vilaine que le
prochain Café du réseau va ouvrir ses
portes début décembre prochain moi j'ai
pas connu
elle résonne tous les premiers mercredis
du mois depuis la Seconde Guerre
mondiale les sirènes d'alerte permettent
vous le savez de prévenir les
populations d'un danger imminent ou en
cours et si le risque de guerre est bien
moindre aujourd'hui celui d'un accident
civil lui ne l'est pas à Limoges la
sirène vieille de 80 ans vient d'être
remplacé sur le toit de l'hôtel de ville
comme vous le voyez sur ces images
aériennes de nos confrères de cet
aliment la commune et notamment située
en aval de plusieurs barrages installés
sur la Vienne précision au micro de
Benjamin Delmas
elles ont été recentrées sur des
événements de sécurité civile et là en
l'occurrence c'est un événement type
d'événement qui est la rupture de
barrage on a des barrages en amont
n'a pas tant que ça mais il y a des gros
barrages en amont qui en cas de rupture
effectivement
nécessiterait une alerte des populations
elles ont envahi les routes et les
trottoirs de nos villes en quelques
années les trottinettes électriques sont
désormais bien installées dans le
paysage urbain
utile pour remplacer les déplacements en
voiture ou en deux roues elle n'en reste
pas moins dangereuse et soumises à des
règles de bonne conduite encore
méconnues celle-ci font l'objet de
rappel à l'ordre par les agents de
police avec pour exemple à Épinal ce
sujet de Ludovic bisilla et Dan Didier
pour vos télévisions
voici une infraction très répandue en
centre-ville à Épinal comme dans toutes
les villes les trottinettes électriques
sont de plus en plus nombreuses c'est
moins encombrants et moins polluants
qu'une voiture donc bon pour
l'environnement mais trop peu de leur
pilote savent qu'une trottinette
électrique et pourtant considérée comme
une voiture elles doivent donc rester
sur la chaussée et moi je roule sur la
route quand il y a personne sur la route
mais des fois je roule sur le trottoir
et pourquoi tu n'as pas le droit
à droite même si le feu rouge de
nouvelles règles de circulation et
surtout un nouveau partage de l'espace
public il faut qu'on s'adapte et que
tout en tout cas que chacun puisse
trouver sa place et en tout cas trouver
une réelle harmonie dans les
déplacements Épinal a lancé son dernier
plan de mobilité au printemps de
nouveaux usages une bonne connaissance
des règles et surtout une acceptation
par tous du partage des axes de
circulation qui demanderont assurément
un peu de temps
des trottinettes au roller transition
toute tracées dans cette édition pour
vous faire découvrir une pratique le
roller derby venu des États-Unis ce
sport physique gagne de plus en plus de
terrain en France à Metz une équipe
féminine fait partie de la troisième
division nationale un mélange de glisse
et de contact étonnant comme vous allez
le voir avec ce sujet de Coline l'expert
pour Moselle télévision
une troupe sur motivée et montée sur
roulettes voilà disant que cette équipe
de roller derby se fait sa place dans le
paysage sportif messin Mélissa la reine
de la mirabelle si émise il y a un an
c'est vraiment par hasard que j'ai
découvert ce sport c'est une amie qui a
dû devenir à des entraînements qu'il
avait à la fête du sport et en fait j'ai
tout de suite accroché entre le patinage
et le sport de contact et l'esprit
d'équipe surtout c'est ça qui m'a motivé
et ses entraînements ont lieu chaque
semaine les 13 joueuses grenats se
retrouvent pour apprendre à marquer
toujours plus de points mais ne cherchez
pas la balle dans ce sport de contact
pour faire exploser le compteur il faut
plutôt jouer des coudes il a 5 joueuses
par équipes sur le trac donc quatre
personnes qui sont en défense et une
personne qui est attaquante qui a une
étoile sur son casque et c'est cette
personne là qui va marquer des points et
pour marquer la James au casque étoilée
doit parvenir à traverser la défense
adverse puis sprinter autour de la piste
un sport intensif qui demande un bon
cardio et de bons équipements pour
amortir les de nombreux chocs si les
tenues customisées et les surnoms
choisis par les Vosges peuvent prêter
assouvir le roller derby n'en reste pas
moins une discipline mondiale on est
donc inscrit dans le championnat de
National 2 notre objectif bah c'est
prouver qu'on a notre place en fait dans
ce championnat l'équipe avait laquelle
on joue c'est celle qu'on avait l'année
dernière et même si l'envie de gagner se
recent chez les grenats l'esprit roller
derby c'est aussi se prouver qu'on est
forte comme dans la vie on apprend à
tomber déjà c'est une des premières
choses qu'on apprend et puis on apprend
à se relever on apprend aussi à beaucoup
communiquer à se soutenir les uns les
unes les autres la communauté derby de
Metz est toujours prête à s'agrandir à
la recherche de casse-cou prête à en
découdre
voilà un sport épatant donc qui nous
conduit vers une autre discipline
surprenante le fit pink tonic un mélange
de ping-pong et de fitness destiné à
séduire à nouveau public en effet en
France 80% des joueurs de tennis de
table sont des hommes alors pour
inverser la tendance le fit ping tonic
promet plaisir et fort reportage dans
l'unique club du Val d'Oise en
Île-de-France des Lisa Anita pour via 95
vous allez vous mettre en appui sur les
avant-bras sur la table j'ai entendu
derrière
pied Flex allier fitness et tennis de
table c'est la promesse du fit ping
tonic objectif
développer le tonus musculaire
l'habileté ou encore les réflexes
ça fait mal car ce soir-là ce sont les
bras et le fessier qui est le dit et les
adhérents de travail au programme de la
séance agilité pongiste la balle doit
passer au-dessus et en dessous de la
barre allez à quoi en dessous aussi les
filles pas que au dessus là sinon c'est
trop facile et pour ça les joueuses
doivent rentrer le ventre et serrer le
postérieur il y a toujours un lien entre
le thème de la séance en fitness et les
exercices de tennis de table quand on
fait les bras on peut faire des smatchs
même si cette salle peut faire poncer le
contraire moins d'un genre de ping-pong
sur 6 est une femme les femmes n'aiment
pas le tennis de table
c'est simple et c'est pour ça qu'elle a
fait des ration pour pouvoir féminiser
les clubs de tennis de table ils ont
créé le fiting pour faire venir les
femmes au tennis de table d'une façon
ludique officiellement reconnue en 2012
le fit pink Tony qui est un pari réussi
pour la Fédération de tennis de table
sur 700 adhérents 90% sont des femmes
comme Christelle et Elena fidèle à leur
activité favorite depuis trois ans ça va
c'est original et en fait moi je trouve
que c'est moins répétitif que le tennis
de table parce que en fait on fait
d'autres mouvements et ça nous permet
aussi de voir autre chose à côté avec
cette unique section de fit ping Tony du
Val d'Oise le club de Saint-Leu-la-Forêt
fait partie des 69 autres en France à
développer cette activité et voilà merci
les filles
il aura tout connu en tant que
journaliste le succès en radio à la
télévision mais aussi dans l’écriture
Philippe Bouvard reste à 92 ans un
personnage public engagé le présentateur
historique des grosses têtes sur RTL
vient de publier un nouvel ouvrage
retraçant sa carrière le petit monde de
don bouvardo aux éditions de l'archipel
et c'est à cette occasion que j'ai eu la
chance de rencontrer Philippe bouvar
chez lui à Cannes il revient notamment
sur la place de la liberté d'expression
dans la société actuelle regardez
vous avez été directeur de rédaction
vous avez été directeur général de
journaux vous avez officié à la
télévision à la radio
vous n'avez pas vu cette évolution
arrivée se faire vous la découvrez pas
du tout je n'ai pas vu comment ça se
fait vous étiez à l'époque de votre
temps
est allé sur près d'admission il y avait
un sac nouveau président
chaque décennies il y avait
un petit progrès enfin qu'on présentait
comme tel où il y avait une petite
reculade où il y avait une loi en plus à
réglement supplémentaire et bon je
disais oh c'est un petit truc et en fait
à cause de ces petits trucs qui se sont
agglomérés la vie a changé le monde je
ne le reconnais plus et je vais vous
dire je sais que ce serait obligé de le
quitter
mais je regretterai très moins de
quitter le monde aujourd'hui que j'aurai
regretté de quitter le monde d'hier
voilà l'entretien exceptionnel de
Philippe Bouvard sera à découvrir sur
TV5 Monde dans l'émission monte-carl
Riviera le dimanche 13 novembre à 12h20
et le mardi 15 novembre à 19h ou en
replay bien sûr sur le site internet TV5
monde.com tout à fait autre chose c'est
l'exposition événement de cet automne à
Bordeaux La Chapelle Sixtine de
Michel-Ange n'ont pas l'oeuvre originale
bien sûr mais la reproduction des
fresques de la chapelle du Vatican
Bordeaux est la deuxième ville de France
a accueillir cette exposition murale
après Lyon au total plus de 30
photographies en grand format permettent
de plonger le visiteur dans l'oeuvre de
l'artiste italien et dans l'époque de la
Renaissance un reportage de Dominique
Parmentier pour TV7 la chaîne du groupe
sud-ouest sur place
c'est au plafond de l'ancienne
manufacture bordelaise du 19e siècle que
l'on peut admirer les 33 fresques de
Michel-Ange qui ornent la voûte de la
chapelle Sixtine parmi les plus connus
celle de la Genèse comme la création
d'Adams de Dieu rejoint ou repoussent
celle de l'homme un chef-d'œuvre réalisé
au début du 16e siècle mais ici il
s'agit bien sûr de reproduction ce sont
des photos photographies haute
définition qui ont été imprimées selon
un procédé qui s'appelle seg silicone
Edge graphics qui en fait nous permet
d'imprimer ces photos aux définitions
sur un tissu spécifique et qui vraiment
vient imiter on va dire l'impression
naturelle de la toile des reproductions
grandeurs nature et présentées
séparément contrairement à l'original on
est loin de l'ambiance monumentale de la
chapelle Sixtine mais l'idée du
concepteur est d'offrir un autre point
de vue complémentaire là l'idée c'est
qu'on vous donne un accès aux fresques
de beaucoup plus proche d'un point de
vue qui est beaucoup plus très proche
alors parfois ça fait un peu bizarre de
pas avoir vraiment le le recul parce que
dans la chapelle sexy on va vraiment
toutes les heures et les unes à côté des
autres mais c'est aussi intéressant et
ça permet de se concentrer sur enfin de
délimiter chaque scène enfin la 34e
fraise celle du jugement dernier dans
l'original de 16 mètres sur 13 or ne le
font de la chapelle Sixtine a été
reproduite ici en version réduite il
faut s'approcher pour apprécier tous les
détails des 390 personnages représentés
par l'artiste
voilà donc un rendez-vous à ne pas
manquer et si vous êtes à Bordeaux
l'exposition de la chapelle Sixtine est
à découvrir jusqu'au dimanche 4 décembre
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition du
Grand JT des territoires merci de nous
avoir suivis on se retrouve très vite
pour une nouvelle édition enfin à tous
[Musique]